[Music]
welcome back to scienceclick today
anechoic rooms
the air that makes up our atmosphere is
made of molecules mainly nitrogen and
oxygen
when an object vibrates it displaces
these molecules which push against each
other forming a wave that travels
through space
this is called a sound
what happens then when a sound wave hits
an obstacle
the vibrating air molecules try to push
the molecules of the obstacle
but these are strongly linked together
the obstacle is solid it is difficult to
make them vibrate
as if they were attached with springs
the molecules of the obstacle resist and
push back against the molecules in the
air
part of the wave still manages to cross
the obstacle and propagates beyond it
but another part of the wave is pushed
back
reflected
it's what we call an echo
[Music]
on earth sound waves are omnipresent
music communications transport whether
we like it or not our environment is a
mixture of sounds which overlap and
bounce everywhere around us
imagine a musician playing the guitar in
a concert hall
[Music]
the music spreads in all directions and
reaches the ears of the public
but the sound bounces off the walls
multiple times and all these echoes are
also received by the audience
the initial sound of the guitar is mixed
with all these waves we call this
reverberation
[Music]
this is what distinguishes the ambience
of a church
from that of a small apartment
[Music]
now imagine that for a scientific
purpose we want to analyze the sound
radiated by an object
for example the sound produced by a
speaker
in this case the reflections are a
problem they disturb the signal we'd
like to measure
to isolate the raw sound emitted by the
speaker we would need to create a very
quiet and empty room one which doesn't
produce any echo
an anechoic room
in this video we will try to build an
anechoic room step by step
to begin with let's try to make the room
perfectly silent
initially the room is not silent our
computer produces a little noise for
instance
a first improvement would be to move the
measuring equipment to another room to
prevent it from being heard
it will serve as a control room
despite this the room is still not
silent other noises come from outside
cars passes passers-by airplanes
to get rid of them we'll rebuild the
walls with very thick concrete that
makes it hard for sound waves to pass
through and will add a layer of sound
insulator a very efficient material for
absorbing sound waves
the presence of trucks or trains passing
by also causes vibrations which are
transmitted into our room
to isolate it from these vibrations
we'll raise the structure and place it
on anti-vibration mounts large damped
springs intended to mitigate vibrations
finally we build a second box all around
the room to finish the isolation
this layer is particularly helpful to
insulate the room from the outside
temperature
[Music]
sound travels faster in warm air because
molecules are more agitated
if we imagine a warm summer day the
edges of the room would heat up compared
to the center and sound waves would
propagate differently there
by insulating the room we make sure that
the temperature stays uniform and that
the waves move evenly at every point
[Music]
at this stage our room is very quiet we
have successfully isolated it from all
external disturbances
but there is still one problem sound
waves are reflected off the walls and
blur the sound we want to measure
to solve this last problem we will raise
the speaker to the center of the room
and cover all the walls with hundreds of
wedges
these are triangular objects made from a
porous material ideal for absorbing
sound
when a wave hits the material all these
zigzags increase the surface available
to absorb it the wave bounces multiple
times trapped within these structures
and dissipates more and more at each
bounce
we've now built an anechoic room
unlike in a normal room sound propagates
freely in all directions without any
obstacle to bounce on
as if the room were infinitely large
[Music]
at the laboratory of mechanics and
acoustics of marseille in france
acoustics experts have unique equipment
a complex of three large anechoic rooms
with exceptional performance each
configured for different applications
the first room is dedicated to auditory
perception
here researchers study the human
auditory system
this room is specifically designed to
place a person or a mannequin with ear
microphones at the center of the volume
perfectly isolated from the outside
researchers study the intelligibility of
speech or our perception of sound in
three dimensions
they also try to characterize our
experience in terms of preferences or
discomfort while hearing certain sounds
a related research topic explores our
perception of sound intensity
or pitch
this work allows us to better understand
how our auditory system works
the second room of the laboratory is
semi-anechoic the ground is not
absorbent so sound can bounce off it
this configuration is more convenient
for some research applications and for
industrials
it can host large objects such as a car
or a washing machine
to measure the intensity of the noise
they produce in order to assess their
performance or their compliance to noise
pollution rules
these products are usually placed on the
ground and it is therefore relevant to
factor in the reflections of the waves
as they also contribute to the total
sound a user will hear
under the room a booth communicates
through a hatch and can host a speaker
to measure how sound passes through an
object
it can be used for instance to determine
if a material is a good acoustic insulin
[Music]
finally the third room the largest one
is mainly dedicated to fundamental
research and is currently aiming at
developing a world premier system
when we hear a sound it is composed of
several frequencies vibrating from 20 to
20 000 times per second
high frequencies correspond to high
pitch
and low frequencies to low pitch
but the lower the sound the longer its
wavelength
and below 100 vibrations per second the
wavelength exceeds several meters and
the wedges are then too small in
comparison they cannot trap the sound
wave
[Music]
the lowest sounds bounce off the walls
as in an ordinary room
to overcome this and create a room that
would be anechoic even for low
frequencies lma researchers are
developing a system that would be the
first of its kind
the idea is to combine the absorbent
coating of the walls with 64 speakers
and 128 microphones acting in real time
to cancel the echoes of low frequencies
when a low sound bounces against the
wall it is detected by the microphones
which immediately inform the speakers to
produce an identical wave but of
opposite sign
the waves that the room fails to absorb
are controlled in real time
and we cancel them by adding new opposed
waves
this is called active control
the same principle is used in noise
cancelling headphones
if air molecules vibrate in one
direction
the speakers immediately react and push
back to cancel their vibration
this very ambitious project which will
resonate on an international scale is
currently under development the room is
already wired up to accommodate this
system and the researchers have had
promising breakthroughs there is good
hope of achieving a world premiere
[Music]
to summarise an anechoic room fulfills
two functions
it creates a silent space isolated from
the outside and minimizes the reflection
of sound off its walls
it is crucial equipment for experts
there are also analogous devices for
studying electromagnetic waves
the three rooms of the laboratory of
mechanics and acoustics of marseille
offer insights around multiple questions
scientific ones we study the radiation
of complex sound sources such as musical
instruments but also the human auditory
system and our perception of sound
technical ones we characterize the sound
radiated by industrial objects or the
acoustic transparency of innovative
materials
and finally public health issues as we
evaluate disturbances in noise pollution
or even look to improve the performance
of cochlear implants intended for people
with deafness
contrary to what is sometimes thought it
is possible to stay inside these rooms
for several hours without any problem
scientists do so during their
experiments however some people can feel
disturbed by this almost absolute
silence
to conclude the lma is currently
developing a system that will be unique
in the world a hybrid anechoic room
equipped with an active control system
in the hope of studying low frequency
sources in real time something which has
remained impossible
until now
[Music]
this video was produced in partnership
with ecosystems provence albuquerque
as part of the video eco scientific
project it was written in collaboration
with the laboratory of mechanics and
acoustics of marseille under the
scientific advice of cedric pined
find out more about the lma's anechoic
rooms on the equations youtube channel
[Music]
you